foreign
good afternoon
before discussing today's meeting let me
briefly address recent developments in
the banking sector
in the past two weeks serious
difficulties at a small number of banks
have emerged
history has shown that isolated banking
problems if left unaddressed can
undermine confidence in healthy Banks
and threaten the ability of the banking
system as a whole to play its vital role
in supporting the savings and Credit
needs of households and businesses
that is why in response to these events
the Federal Reserve working with the
treasury Department and the FDIC took
decisive actions to protect the U.S
economy and to strengthen public
confidence in our banking system
these actions demonstrate that all
depositors savings and the banking
system are safe
with the support of the treasury the
Federal Reserve board created the bank
term funding program to ensure that
banks that hold safe and liquid assets
can if needed borrow reserves against
those assets at par
this program along with our
long-standing discount window
is effectively meeting the unusual
funding needs that some banks have faced
and makes clear that ample liquidity in
the system is available
our banking system is sound and
resilient with strong capital and
liquidity
we will continue to closely monitor
conditions in the banking system and are
prepared to use all of our tools as
needed to keep it safe and sound
in addition we are committed to learning
the lessons from this episode and to
work to prevent episodes from events
like this
from happening again
turning to the broader economy and
monetary policy inflation remains too
high and the labor market continues to
be very tight
my colleagues and I understand the
hardship that high inflation is causing
and we remain strongly committed to
Bringing inflation back down to our two
percent goal
price stability is the responsibility of
the Federal Reserve without price
stability the economy does not work for
anyone
in particular without price stability we
will not achieve a sustained period of
long of strong labor market conditions
that benefit all
the US economy slowed significantly last
year with real GDP rising at a below
Trend pace of 0.9 percent
consumer spending appears to have picked
up this quarter although some of that
strength May reflect the effects of
swings in the weather across the turn of
the year
in contrast activity in the housing
sector remains weak largely reflecting
higher mortgage rates
higher interest rates and slower output
growth also appear to be weighing on
business fixed investment
committee participants generally expect
subdued growth to continue
as shown in our summary of economic
projections
the median projection for real GDP
growth stands at just 0.4 percent this
year and 1.2 percent next year
well below the median estimate of the
longer run normal growth rate
and nearly all participants see the
risks to GDP growth as weighted to the
downside
yet the labor market remains extremely
tight
job gains have picked up in recent
months with employment Rising by an
average of 351 000 jobs per month over
the last three months
the unemployment rate remained low in
February at 3.6 percent
the labor force participation rate has
edged up in recent months and wage
growth has shown some signs of easing
however with job vacancies still very
high labor demand substantially exceeds
the supply of available workers
fomc participants expect supply and
demand conditions in the labor market to
come into better balance over time
easing upward pressures on wages and
prices
the median unemployment rate projection
in the SCP Rises to 4.5 percent at the
end of this year
and 4.6 percent at the end of next year
inflation remains well above our longer
run goal of two percent
over the 12 months ending in January
total pce Prices rose 5.4 percent
excluding the volatile food and energy
categories
core PC or excluding excluding those
core pce prices Rose 4.7 percent
in February the 12-month change in the
CPI came in at six percent in the change
in the core CPI was 5.5 percent
inflation has moderated somewhat since
the middle of last year but the strength
of these recent readings indicates that
inflation pressures continue to run High
the median projection the SCP for total
pce inflation is 3.3 percent for this
year 2.5 percent next year and 2.1
percent in 2025.
the process of getting inflation back
down to two percent has a long way to go
and is likely to be bumpy
despite elevated inflation longer term
inflation expectations appear to remain
well anchored as reflected in a broad
range of surveys of households
businesses and forecasters as well as
measures from financial markets
the fed's monetary policy actions are
Guided by our mandate to promote maximum
employment and stable prices for the
American people
my colleagues and I are acutely aware
that high inflation imposes significant
hardship as it erodes purchasing power
especially for those least able to meet
the higher costs of Essentials like food
housing and transportation
we are highly attentive to the risks
that high inflation poses to both sides
of our mandate and we are strongly
committed to returning inflation to our
two percent objective
at today's meeting the committee raised
the target range for the federal funds
rate by a quarter percentage Point
bringing the target range to four and
three quarters to five percent
and we are continuing the process of
significantly significantly reducing our
Securities Holdings
since our previous fomc meeting economic
indicators have generally come in
stronger than expected demonstrating
greater momentum in economic activity
and inflation
We Believe however that events in the
banking system over the past two weeks
are likely to result in tighter credit
conditions for households and businesses
which would in turn affect economic
outcomes
it is too soon to determine the extent
of these effects and therefore too soon
to tell how monetary policy should
respond
as a result we no longer state that we
anticipate that ongoing rate increases
will be appropriate to coil inflation
instead we now anticipate that some
additional policy affirming may be
appropriate
we will closely monitor incoming data
and carefully assess the actual and
expected effects of tighter credit
conditions on economic activity the
labor market and inflation
and our policy decisions will reflect
that assessment
in our SCP each fomc participant wrote
down an appropriate path for the federal
funds rate based on what that
participant judges to be the most likely
scenario going forward
if the economy evolves as projected the
meeting participant projects that the
appropriate level of the federal funds
rate will be 5.1 percent at the end of
this year
4.3 percent at the end of 2024
and 3.1 percent at the end of 2025.
these are little changed from our
December projections reflecting
offsetting factors
these projections are not a committee
decision or plan if the economy does not
evolve as projected the path for policy
will adjust as appropriate to Foster our
maximum employment and price stability
goals
we will continue to make our meeting
decisions meeting by meeting based on
the totality of the incoming data and
their implications for the outlook for
economic activity and inflation
we remain committed to Bringing
inflation back down to our two percent
goal and to keep longer-term inflation
expectations well anchored
reducing inflation is likely to require
a period of below Trend growth and some
softening in labor market conditions
restoring price stability is essential
to set the stage for achieving maximum
employment and stable prices over the
longer run
to conclude we understand that our
actions affect communities families and
businesses across the country everything
we do is in service to our public
mission
we at the FED will do everything we can
to achieve our maximum employment and
price stability goals thank you I look
forward to your questions
Financial Times how confident is the
committee that the recent stress that
we've seen and you've alluded to is
contained at this point and that deposit
flight among mid-sized lenders in
particular has ceased
thanks so I guess our view is that the
banking system is sound and it's
resilient it's got strong Capital
liquidity
we took powerful actions with Treasury
and the FDIC which demonstrate that all
depositors savings are safe and that the
banking system is safe
deposit flows in the banking system have
stabilized over the last week
and the last thing I'll say is that
we've undertaken we're undertaking a
thorough internal review that will
identify where we can strengthen
supervision and regulation
okay uh just a quick follow-up I mean
given all of the stress and the
uncertainty that you've also alluded to
in the statement how seriously was a was
a pause considered for this meeting
so we considered um we did consider that
in the Days running up to the meeting
and you see the decision that we made
which
I'll say a couple things about first it
was supported by a very strong consensus
and I'll be happy to explain why and
really it is that the the intermediate
data on inflation and the labor market
came in stronger than expected and
really before the recent events we were
clearly on track to continue with
ongoing rate hikes in fact as of a
couple of weeks ago it looked like we
need to raise rates over the course of
the year more than we'd expected at the
time of the SCP in December the time of
December meeting
we are committed to restoring price
stability and all of the evidence says
that the public has confidence that we
will do so that will bring inflation
down to two percent over time it is
important that we sustain that
confidence with our actions as well as
our words
so we also assess as I mentioned that
the events of the last two weeks are
likely to result in some tightening and
credit conditions for households and
businesses and thereby way on demand on
the labor market
and on inflation
such a tightening in financial
conditions would would work in the same
direction as rate tightening in
Principle as a matter of fact you can
think of it as being the equivalent of a
rate hike or perhaps more than that of
course it's not possible to make that
assessment assessment today with any
Precision whatsoever
so our decision was to move ahead with a
25 basis point hike and to change our
guidance as I mentioned from ongoing
hikes to uh
some some additional hikes maybe some
policy firming may be appropriate
so going forward
as I mentioned in assessing the need for
for further hikes will be focused as
always on the incoming data and the
evolving Outlook and in particular on
our assessment of the actual unexpected
effects of credit tightening
see
Mr chair can you explain
um
the difference between ongoing rate
increases and Firming um does firming
imply a rate increase per se or could
policy firm Without You increasing rates
no I think it's it's meant to refer to
our policy rate really I would focus on
on the words may and some
as opposed to ongoing
ongoing so we we clearly were what we
were doing there was taking on board the
on trying to reflect the uncertainty
about what will happen I mean it's
possible that this will turn out to have
very modest effects these events will
turn out to be a very very modest
effects on the economy in which case and
inflation will continue to be strong in
which case the you know the path will
look uh might look different it's also
possible that this potential tightening
will contribute significant uh
tightening in credit conditions over
time and in principle if that that
that's that means that monetary policy
may have less work to do we simply don't
know uh so do you have concerns at the
recent that heike did today could
further exacerbate the problem in the
banks
no I mean we're with our monetary policy
we're we're really focused on
macroeconomic outcomes in particular
we're focused on on this potential
credit tightening and what can that
produce in the way of tighter credit
conditions I think when we think about
uh the situation in the banks we're
focused on our on our financial
stability Tools in particular uh our
lending facilities uh the the debt uh
sorry the discount window and also the
new facility
Nick
timmeros of the Wall Street Journal uh
chair Powell in your testimony two weeks
ago you had indicated you thought the
terminal rate would be higher obviously
that was before the stress in the
banking sector and I realized there's a
lot of uncertainty but can you can you
explain it all to what extent
your forecasts or those of your
colleagues or those of the board staff
Incorporated today a material tightening
of credit availability because of the
stress in the banking sector or are you
waiting to see it in the data before you
incorporate
that potential tightening into your
forecasts so you know we've just come
from an fomc meeting and uh you know the
the people who write the minutes will be
very carefully counting but I'll tell
you what I heard what I heard was
significant number of people saying that
they anticipated there would be some
some tightening your credit conditions
and that would
really have the same effects as as our
policies do and that therefore they were
including that in their assessment and
that if that did turned out not to be
the case that in principle you'd need
more rate hikes so some people did
reflect that uh in their in their uh
from in their SCP forecasts I think
there may also just have been remember
this is 12 days ago you know we're
trying to assess something that just is
so recent and it's people you know it's
very difficult there's so much
uncertainty so December was a good place
to start and we wound up with we wound
up with very similar outcomes for
December
and it you know in a way the the early
the data in in the first part the first
five weeks of the intermediate period
pointed to Stronger inflation and
stronger labor markets so that pointed
to higher rates and then this this
latter part kind of uh the possibility
of of uh of uh credit conditions
tightening really really offset that
effectively to follow up have you
considered at all whether your primary
tool the funds rate is going to be
enough to sustain the kind of tighter
Financial conditions that you believe
will be necessary without doing
significant damage to the banking sector
have you for example considered changing
reserve requirements selling assets out
of the system open market account as a
way to better achieve entire Financial
conditions that don't
accelerate deposit erosion for example
from Banks
you know we know that we have other
other tools in effect but no we think
our monetary policy tool works and we
think uh you know many many banks uh our
rate hikes were well telegraphed to the
market and many banks have managed to to
handle them
hi Victoria Guido with Politico I wanted
to ask um you along with the FDIC and
the treasury the FED board decided to
invoke the systemic risk exception
um to allow uninsured depositors to be
protected at these two Banks and I was
just wondering if you could speak to why
that decision was made was it purely a
confidence issue or where was there a
concern that there would be some sort of
economic contagion or financial
contagion from the failure of these
Banks
the issue was really not about those
specific Banks but about about the risk
of of a contagion to to other Banks and
to the financial markets more broadly
that was the issue
okay and then can you also just a
follow-up can you speak to the role that
you will be playing in the fed's
internal investigation on its
supervision and regulation so Vice chair
bar is is of course leading that review
and uh he's responsible for it in his
capacity as Vice chair for supervision
uh we uh I realized you know right away
that that there was going to be a need
for a review I mean the question we're
all asking ourselves over that first
weekend was how did this happen and uh
so what we did was
early Monday morning we sat down and
said let's do this and he's he was
obviously going to lead it in his
capacity so I don't you know my uh my
role was to announce it and uh I I get
briefed on it but I'm not involved in in
the work of it
uh chair pal uh Howard Schneider from
Reuters so um I want to go back to your
February press conference you mentioned
the word disinflation I believe uh nine
or ten times the process that you felt
was uh uh uh I forget the word you used
but gratefully underway or something
like that is disinflation still
occurring in the U.S today
yes I mean what actually happened Howard
was I got the question 12 times so it's
a maybe it's a feature not a bug but uh
so but yeah absolutely the price
absolutely the same the story is is
intact so it's really three parts right
Goods inflation's been coming down now
for six months it's proceeding more
slowly than we would have liked but it's
certainly proceeding
um Housing Services is is really a
matter of time passing we continue to
see the new leases being signed at much
lower levels of inflation so that's 44
of the of the core pce index where
you've got a story that's ongoing where
we didn't have in February and we still
don't have now is a sign of progress in
the non-housing services sector and that
is um it you know that's just something
that we'll have to come through through
softening demand and perhaps some
softening in labor market conditions we
don't see that yet and that's that's of
course 56 percent of the index so the
story is pretty much the same I will say
that the inflation data that we got to
your point really pointed to Stronger
inflation if I could follow up on that I
was curious why you don't see more
coming from the credit crunch because it
seems to me that's like something that
you'd actually uh welcome to a degree
and uh expect
um and are you not seeing more coming
from that because you don't know or
because you just don't want to have
another round of wishful thinking so
it's really just a question of not
knowing at this point there's a great
deal of literature on the connection
between tighter credit conditions
economic activity hiring and inflation
very large body of literature the
question is how significant will this
credit tightening be and how how
sustained will it be that's that's the
issue and we don't really see it yet
it's so so people are making estimates
you know people are publishing estimates
and it's but it's very kind of rule of
thumb uh guesswork almost at this point
but we think it's it's potentially quite
real and that argues for you know being
alert as we go forward as we think about
further rate hikes for us we'll be
paying attention to the actual
unexpected effect from that
Gina
hi chair pal Gina Smiley from The New
York Times thank you for taking our
questions
um I wonder if you could talk a little
bit I know that you've got your internal
review coming but I wonder if you could
talk a little bit about what you think
happened with oversight at Silicon
Valley Bank and whether this suggests
that something about regulation and
supervision needs to actually change
going forward and I wonder you know how
can the American people have confidence
that there aren't other weaknesses out
there in the banking system given that
this one got missed as you noted
so let me let me say what what I think
happened and then I'll come to
the questions around supervision so at a
basic level uh Silicon Valley Bank
management failed badly they grew the
bank very quickly they exposed the bank
to significant liquidity risk and
interest rate risk didn't hedge that
risk we now know that supervisors uh saw
these risks and and intervened we know
that the public saw all this
we know that svb experienced an
unprecedentedly rapid and massive Bank
room so this is a this is a very large
group of connected depositors
concentrated group of connected
depositors in a very very fast run
faster than historical record would
suggest so
um
for as for us so for our part we're
doing a review of supervision and
regulation
my only interest is that we identify
what went wrong here how did this happen
is the question what went wrong
try to find that we will find that and
then make an assessment of what are the
right policies to put in place so that
it doesn't happen again and then
Implement those policies
it would be inappropriate for me at this
stage to offer my views on what the
answers might be you know I simply can't
do that Vice chair bar is leading this
and uh I think he's testifying next week
so but that will be up to him so that's
really where it is you know the um
the review is going to be thorough and
transparent uh it is clear to your
really to your last question it's
clearly we do need to strengthen
supervision or regulation
uh and I I assume that uh you know there
will be recommendations coming out of
the report and I I plan on supporting
them and supporting their implementation
right just and the final point you know
can we feel confident that these
weaknesses don't Exist Elsewhere given
that they got missed at this Bank
these are not weaknesses that are that
are at all broadly through the banking
system this was a this was a bank that
was an outlier in terms of both its
percentage of of uh of um of uninsured
deposits and in in terms of its uh
Holdings of duration risk and again
supervisors did get in there and and
they were as you know uh obviously uh
you know they they were they were on
this issue but nonetheless this this
still happened and and so that's really
the nature of the interview sorry of the
review is to discover that
Michael McKee from Bloomberg radio and
television you've been very consistent
in saying that the FED would be raising
interest rates and then holding them
there for quite some time uh following
today's decision the markets have now
priced in uh one more increase in May
and then every meeting the rest of this
year their pricing in rate Cuts uh are
they getting this totally wrong from the
fed or is there something different
about the way uh you're looking at it
given that you're now thinking that
moves might be appropriate as opposed to
ongoing so we published an SCP today as
you will have seen and it shows that uh
basically participants expect uh
relatively slow growth a gradual
rebalancing of supply and demand in a
labor market with inflation moving down
gradually
in that most likely case if that happens
participants don't see rate Cuts this
year they just don't
I would just say as always the path of
the economy is uncertain and policy is
going to reflect what actually happens
rather than what we write down in the
SCP but that's not our Baseline
expectation well if I could follow up
and ask um as you look forward uh into
the rest of the year here are you saying
that what you see and the 5.1 percent
basically consensus is based on being it
will be sufficiently restrictive or is
it leavened by the idea of you don't
know what's going to happen in other
words what should people think about in
terms of how the FED thinks about how
far it is from the terminal it's going
to depend remember we're looking for
purposes of our monetary policy tool
we're looking at what's happening among
the banks and asking is there going to
be some tightening and credit conditions
and then we're thinking about that as
effectively doing the same thing that
rate hikes do so in a way that
substitutes for rate hikes so the the
key is we have to have policies need got
to be tight enough to bring inflation
down to two percent over time it doesn't
all have to come from Radix it can come
from uh you know from tighter credit
conditions so that we're looking at and
we it's highly uncertain how long the
situation will be sustained or how
significant any of those effects would
be so we're just going to have to watch
in the meantime
you know and obviously at the end of the
day we will do enough to bring inflation
down to two percent no one should doubt
that
hi chair Powell Rachel
rage post thank you for taking our
questions I know we've talked a bit
about how Silicon Valley Bank was unique
to a certain sector of the economy but
there's also growing concern that there
are Financial stability risks from the
commercial real estate market and loans
that will begin to roll over later this
year and next and that smaller Regional
Banks also disproportionately hold those
loans is there a risk that could mimic
the kind of what we saw with svb to
banks that disproportionately are
focused in commercial real estate so you
know we've well aware of the
concentrations people have in commercial
real estate I really don't think it's
comparable to this the bank the banking
system is is strong it is sound it is uh
resilient it's well capitalized
and I really don't see that as at all
analogous to this
the question would you be open to an
independent investigation separate from
the fed's probe I welcome
it's it's a hundred percent certainty
that there will be independent
investigations and outside
investigations and all that so we
welcome
when a bank fails there are
investigations and of course we welcome
that
thank you Mr chairman uh Edward Lawrence
from Fox Business inflation has been
rather sticky so do you need help from
the fiscal side to get inflation down
faster
we don't assume that we don't give
advice to the fiscal authorities and we
we assume that um we take fiscal policy
as as it comes to our front door
stick it in our model along with a
million other things and uh we have
responsibility for Price stability the
Federal Reserve has a responsibility for
that and
nothing is going to change that so we
and we will get inflation down to two
percent in time
and if I can follow on that but they're
working the the spending that's happened
is working against what you are doing
right so it's prolonging inflation
you know if you you have to look at um
at the impulse from spending because
spending was of course tremendously High
during the pandemic and then as the
pandemic programs uh rolled off spending
actually came down so the the sort of
fiscal impulse is actually not what's
driving inflation right now it was it
was at the beginning perhaps part of
what was driving inflation but that's
not really the story now
let's go to Neil Irwin
hi Char pal uh Neil Irwin with axios um
two questions about aspects of the
government's response on Silicon Valley
Bank two weekends ago first why is this
new bank funding facility uh done under
emergency 13-3 Authority as opposed to
expansion the discount window changing
the terms of the discount window that's
been around a long time and second can
you discuss the fed's role in uh in the
FDIC guarantee of uninsured depositors
and why there's 143 billion dollars on
your balance sheet last week supporting
a deposit guarantee sure so
13-3 uh seemed like the right we have a
little more flexibility on under Section
13 through we did we've done quite a lot
under the discount window as well we
needed to do a special facility that was
designed a certain way so we did it
under 13-3
um really no magic to that it's only
available in unusual and circumstances
and it has to be meet certain
requirements but it seemed to be the
right place so we with the FDIC we're
just we're lending to the in effect
we're we're lending to the bridge bank
so that's where the funds came from and
it's it's a loan that's 100 guaranteed
by the FDIC so there's no risk in it for
us
okay Chris we're gamer
uh thank you Chris rugaber and
Associated Press the SCB SCP suggests
one more rate hike as does the change in
the language in the statement
um and which suggests that you're
perhaps nearing the end of a cycle of
rate hikes uh do you feel though that if
inflation remains high you'll be able to
resume additional hikes as needed or
have you somewhat tied your hands here
with these signals about rate hikes
coming to an end thank you absolutely
not no we we if we need to raise height
raise rates higher we will
I think for now though we we as I've
mentioned we see the likelihood of of
credit tightening we know that that can
have a you know an effect on the macro
economy on demand on labor market on
inflation and we're going to be watching
to see what that is and we'll also be
watching it what's happening with
inflation and in the labor market so
we'll be watching all those things and
of course we will we will eventually get
to tight enough policy to bring
inflation down to two percent uh we'll
we'll find ourselves at that place
hi chair Powell thanks for taking the
question Kyle Campbell with American
Banker I have a couple questions about
the balance sheet uh first of all I'm
curious uh at what point the financial
supports that the FED is extending uh
through the discount window and through
its enhanced lending facility uh might
be at odds with the objective of
reducing the balance sheet and I'm also
curious what your thoughts are on uh the
not just the availability of reserves
but the distribution of them throughout
the banking system and at what point you
might be concerned about it being scarce
for certain Banks
so um
so people think of QE and qt in
different ways so let me be clear about
how I'm thinking about these recent
developments
so the recent liquidity provision that
has increased the size of our balance
sheet but the intent and the effects of
it are very different from what we from
when we expand our balance sheet through
purchases of longer term Securities
large-scale purchases of long-term
Securities are are really meant to alter
The Stance of policy by pushing down
pushing up the price and down the rates
longer term rates which supports demand
through channels we understand fairly
well
the balance sheet expansion is really
temporary lending to Banks to meet those
special liquidity demands created by the
recent tensions it's not intended to
directly alter The Stance of monetary
policy
we do believe that it's working it's
having its intended effect of bolstering
confidence in the banking system and
thereby forestalling what might
otherwise have been an Abrupt and
outsized tightening and financial
conditions so that's working in terms of
the distribution of Reserves
um we we don't see ourselves as as as
running into Reserve shortages we we
think that our you know our program of
allowing our balance sheet to run off
predictably predictably and passively is
working
and um of course we're we're always
prepared to to change that if that
changes but we don't see any evidence
that that's changed
[Music]
um
hi chair Katarina survival with
Bloomberg News
um the minutes of the January February
meeting the last meeting indicate that
you discuss the possibility of runs on
non-bank financial institutions and the
impact of large unrealized losses on
Bank portfolios can you talk a little
bit more about that discussion kind of
what was talked about in light of that
and then widened the fed you know do
anything about that at that point to
ultimately prevent you know what
happened this month I mean to be honest
I don't I don't recall the specifics of
that it's been it's quite an interesting
seven weeks but um but I will tell you
though that we we have there have been
presentations about about interest rate
risk I mean it's been in all the
newspapers it's not a surprise that
there are institutions that have that
have had unhedged long positions in long
duration Securities that have lost value
as as longer term rates have gone up due
to our rate increases so that's that's
not a surprise
um I I think as you know as as it is now
on the public record the supervisory
team was apparently engaged very much
engaged with the bank
repeatedly and was escalating but you
know nonetheless what happened happened
and so that's really the purpose of one
way to think about the review that Vice
chair
bar is conducting is to try to
understand how that happened and try to
understand how we can do better and and
what policies we need to change I mean
one one thing is the speed of the I'll
come back to that the speed of the uh
uh of the run it's it's very different
from what we've seen in the past and it
does kind of suggest uh that there's a
need for possible you know Regulatory
and supervisory changes just because
supervision regulation need to keep up
with what's hap what's happening in the
world can you confirm whether or not the
board knew about these escalations by
the uh exam examiners in San Francisco
I I have to come back to you on that
yeah I don't know
uh Simon urbanovic with the economist
thank you very much
um chair Powell you've stated twice
today that all depositors Savings in the
banking system are safe
um are you saying that de facto deposit
insurance covers all savings
um shouldn't Congress have a say in that
and just by way of example if a bank
with less than a billion dollars in
assets failed are you promising to bail
out all of its depositors
well I'm I'm not saying anything more
than I'm saying so uh but what I'm
saying is you you've seen that we have
the tools to protect depositors when uh
there's a threat of serious harm to the
economy or to or to the financial system
and we're prepared to use those tools
and I think depositors should assume
that they're that they're deposits are
safe
thank you chairpower Greg Rob from
MarketWatch I was wondering if you could
give us a little bit more of the color
you gave just a little bit of color you
said during the first week of the
Silicon Valley weekend you said the
question you guys asked was how did this
happen when you saw Silicon Valley Bank
so I was wondering if you could go to
the Credit Suisse merger I mean wasn't
that the big gorilla in the room aren't
you didn't you breathe a sigh of relief
when that uh merger happened thanks
sure so you know we that that was really
the Swiss government we of course were
following it over the course of the
weekend and we were engaged with their
authorities in the way that you would
expect all the ways that you would
expect it seems to have been a positive
outcome in the sense that uh the
transaction was agreed to and it has
been uh the markets have accepted it and
uh
it seems to have seems to have gone well
and I think there was a concern that it
might not go well so coming coming into
the middle of this week yes I would say
that that has gone well so far
hi thank you chair pal Nicole good kind
with CNN business uh in the summary of
economic projections the fomcu sees the
unemployment rate increasing to 4.5
percent this year I'm wondering how you
anticipate uh preventing this from
snowballing while using the admittedly
blunt tools at your disposal
so that's just that's an estimate
um of uh what will happen as as demand
slows
and as conditions soften in the labor
market and it's just it's um it's a
highly uncertain estimate and um
I mean I I was really we we have to
bring inflation down to two percent
the costs of bringing it down there are
real costs to bring it down to two
percent but the cost of failing are much
higher and if you read your history as
you I'm sure you have you can see that
if if the central bank doesn't get
inflation back in place get inflation
make sure that inflation expectations
remain anchored you can have a long
series of years where inflation is high
and volatile and uh it's it's hard to
invest Capital it's hard for an economy
to perform well and that's we're looking
to avoid that and uh you know and to get
back to where we need to be back to
where we were for a quarter century and
get there as quickly as we can
historically it's been hard to contain
unemployment and I the question is do
you worry about some sort of Snowball
Effect and how do you factor that into
your your projections and your thoughts
it it depends on whether you we so
recessions tend to be non-linear and so
they're very hard to model you know the
models all work in a kind of linear way
if you have more of this you get more of
that but when a recession happens the
reactions tend to be non-linear and
that's what it so we don't know whether
that'll happen this time we don't know
if so we don't know what how significant
it will be and so you know we're we're
very focused on getting inflation down
uh and uh because we know in the longer
run that that is the thing that will
most benefit the people we serve that's
how we can have a long you know we've
had very strong labor markets through
these long expansions that we've had
four of the five longest or three of the
four longest expansions in U.S history
have been really since the high
inflation period And the reason was
inflation wasn't forcing the central
bank to come in and stop an incipient or
or you know a an expansion you can have
very very long expansions without high
inflation and we had several of those
and they're very good for people you see
latent expansion you see low
unemployment you see the benefits of
wages going to people at the lower end
of the wage Spectrum it's it's just a
place that we should try to get back to
Gene
hi chair pal Gene Young with market news
I just wanted to ask with all the events
of the past two weeks do you still see a
possibility of a soft Landing for the
U.S economy
you know it's it's too early to say
really whether uh
whether these events have had much of an
effect I it's hard for me to see how
they would have helped the problem the
possibility but I guess I would just say
it's it's too early to say whether there
really have been
um changes in that you know the question
will be how long this period is
sustained the longer it's sustained then
the greater will be the the
um the likely uh
declines in in or tightening and credit
standards
credit availability so we'll just have
to see I do still think though that
there's a there's a pathway to that I
think that pathway still exists and um
you know we're certainly trying to find
it
high chair pal Nancy Marshall against
her with Marketplace just wondering how
many financial institutions have been
issued matters requiring retention or
matters requiring immediate attention
citations at this point how many I don't
know
but those are serious those are serious
regulatory particularly immediate
attention that's that's uh
and I guess there were six of them so
and and getting to the seriousness of it
how are you going to ensure that Banks
comply with these citations take them
seriously how we enforce them that that
is a great question and is right in the
heart of what the uh
um the review will be doing under Vice
chair of bars leadership so that's
I think that's where that's what you
think about you know what what can we do
to make sure
that but again that's not for me to
answer today I have specific thoughts on
that well I see if I did I wouldn't
share them because I I I I really you
know this this review is going on and
you know I wanna I I want nothing other
than us to find out what happened and
why
figure out what we can do to do better
and then Implement those changes that's
all I want it's for me to be giving you
my half-formed or partially informed
thoughts you know it just isn't
appropriate the the there's a real
serious review going on with with people
from all over the Federal Reserve System
who were not connected to this you know
to this uh work not connected to this
bank and uh under under again uh Vice
chair Bar's leadership and I'm I'm
confident that it will produce a
satisfactory result
okay we'll go to Jennifer for the last
question
thank you chair pal Jennifer schonberger
with Yahoo finance curious how do you
view Financial conditions right now if
credit becomes expensive enough choking
off growth as you said you're watching
before would that situation warrant a
rate cut what situation would warrant a
rate cut and have the bank failures
prompted any discussion around changing
the implementation of the balance sheet
runoff thank you
so we haven't really talked about
changing the balance sheet
implementation that's not something
we've discussed yet as I mentioned we're
always willing to change that if we
conclude that it's appropriate but we're
really not seeing any signs there sorry
then the question before that was just
give me a
um curious uh how you View financial
conditions
the credit where to tighten enough
so
um
Financial conditions seem to have
tightened and probably by more than the
traditional indexes say because the
traditional indexes are are focused a
lot on rates and equities and they don't
necessarily capture
um lending conditions so we think that
though so there are other measures which
which if they're focused on you know
Bank lending conditions and things like
that they show some more tightening the
question for us though is how
significant will that be and how you
know what would be the extent of it and
what we will be the duration of it and
and then you know once you have once you
know that
there's a fair amount of research about
how that how that with broad uncertainty
bands how that works its way into the
economy over what period of time and so
you know so we'll be looking to see the
first part of that like how serious is
this and how does it look like it's
going to be sustained and if it is you
know it could easily have a significant
macroeconomic effect and we would factor
that into our into our policy decisions
I mentioned with rate Cuts it's rate
cuts are not in our base case uh and uh
you know so
that's all I have to say so
thank you very much